hi everybody i'm jonathan chanson the  world-famous st. louis chess club and  today i got another tactical challenge  for you so when you see the position on  your screen go ahead and pause the video  and we'll see if you can solve it in  this position it's black to move do you  have it here comes a solution well  hopefully this wasn't very tricky for  you guys there is a pin on the e-file so  blacks best move is the very simple  Queen takes Bishop winning a piece I  hope you enjoyed this video  congratulations to everybody that was  able to get this one right and if you  like what you see go ahead and subscribe  to our channel so you can see more  material just like this thank you for  watching